so I've said before I don't really
believe in using this type of language
as legitimate political language but but
it's sort of is the right language to
use here
Trump's been totally cooked by Vladimir
Putin and I know that Pat gets very very
upset when I use that kind of language
and he pulls me aside after the show and
we often have to have a conversation
that that embarrasses max because of how
crazy it gets but he's been totally cut
by Putin who has rejected Trump's
invitation to the White House into
Washington DC one of the things that
came out of the Helsinki summit other
than the sort of undeniable obvious
confirmation that Trump is a total
captive of Vladimir Putin's is that
Trump wants Putin at the White House
they were calling it a sort of second
summit but this time not on neutral
ground like Helsinki but rather on Putin
oh sorry
Freudian slip on Trump's turf Washington
DC in the United States and it wasn't
really clear whether this was a good
idea or a bad idea
until yesterday when Russia announced
that they're gonna reject the invitation
they're rejecting Trump's offer for a
summit and it is making Trump once again
look like the humiliated fool that he is
getting played by world leaders all over
the world and when you think about one
of Putin's top goals as meddling in the
2016 election to destabilize American
democracy and to make Russia seem like a
power player the Alpha around the world
this is the exact message that is
reinforced when Russia says Oh Trump
invited Putin to the White House no
thanks this isn't the right time and for
the time being
Russia is saying no trouble top Putin
Kremlin aid Yuri ochakov said quote
after the summit you know what kind of
atmosphere there is around its outcome I
think it would be wise to let the dust
settle and then we can discuss all these
questions in a businesslike way but not
now and this invitation was not some
random offhanded statement from Trump
just last week Trump and White House
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
said preparations were already underway
for the visit right you don't say you're
already preparing for the visit unless
you're thinking about it as a serious
thing and now Putin says now can't be
bothered right now me
maybe some other time Trump even tweeted
about it last week saying the summit
with Russia was a great success except
with the real enemy of the people the
fake news media I look forward to our
second meeting so that we can start
implementing some of the many things
discussed including stopping terrorism
security for Israel nuclear
proliferation cyberattacks trade Ukraine
Middle East peace North Korea and more
there are many answers some easy and
some hard to these problems but they can
all be solved
apparently not with Putin at the White
House though ouch totally played once
again right Putin is kind of like the
pickup artist and Trump is the naive
youngster who thinks he's such a nice
guy
why wouldn't I go on another date with I
was thinking that this was gonna stir up
Trump's daddy issues right I think Trump
has one of those complexes where his dad
never truly accepted him yeah so he was
always upset with himself right had to
have his dad bail him out so many times
with his business endeavors right I like
the same thing right if we think that
Trump is Putin working for Putin and yet
Putin won't even visit the White House
that's kind of shame him the art of the
deal this guy I mean can you think of a
worse deal maker than Trump in politics
Putin is just straight-up toying with
the guy but we got along so well in
Helsinki and now he says he doesn't want
to play in my sandbox how many times
from get humiliated by Putin before the
Trump is say enough is enough
sky is embarrassing our country
unfortunately it's a very very high
number I don't think I don't think we're
anywhere close to the number of times
Trump needs to get humiliated by Putin
before the trumpets will say this might
not be working out as well as the so
called the renewed friendship with
Russia was supposed to be working out
the trumpets don't care they're gonna
stick with them it could have been
Russia who declined the information the
invitation it could have been Israel who
declined the invitation it could've been
a 400-pound man sitting on a bed
somewhere who listen there's nearly 200
countries out there so the fact that
Russia is not coming to Washington DC
could actually relate to Equatorial
Guinea --hz decision or maybe the
Chilean President made the call
could be anybody tons of countries out
there as Donald Trump often likes to say
today's program is made possible in part
by futur witch
or is a social forecasting game where
you compete with other players to
predict the future and it's built on the
principles of what's called a prediction
market a scientifically proven way of
using the wisdom of the crowd to create
more accurate predictions about future
events prediction markets have been
shown to work much better than other
forecasting methods like polling or
expert analysis in many cases and futur
has actually taken the concept and
turned it into a fun easy to use social
game you open up the futur app and
you'll see a whole range of forecasts
covering topics across the board from
politics to sports and everything in
between you can check out my predictions
and follow me to get updates on my
profile which is linked to in the
description if you're watching this on
YouTube the tour is a great tool to find
out more about the world improve your
forecasting ability show off your
prediction skills to friends and even
better when you make predictions on
futur you're helping to create more
accurate forecasts for everybody their
mission of creating better predictions
is great and actually going in there and
seeing how well you can do at predicting
the future can be kind of addicting go
to futur com sign up and start making
forecast it's free and it's available on
both Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers and that's f you t you you are
calm